so donald trump's niece mary trump is
again weighing in on what she believes
is the growing fear in her uncle donald
trump uh of the walls closing in around
him and criminality enveloping him and
possibly leading to charges and we're
going to look at a clip of her appearing
on i believe it's msnbc to talk about
this and i do find it interesting but at
the same time and if i'm wrong please
tell me
i appreciate the perspective
of someone from trump's family and when
she first emerged from the shadows
it was particularly interesting but now
i'm actually wondering
what mary trump really knows about
what's going on right now with donald
trump because as far as i know she has
no contact with him or that side of the
family whatsoever so let's take a listen
this is interesting and it may well be
what donald trump is feeling but it may
be just as speculative as what i can
deduce trump might be feeling from his
post on truth social more than any
personal knowledge let's take a look
joining me now is donald trump's niece
mary trump she's the author of too much
and never enough mary good morning
always good to see you uh listen by your
training you are a psychologist and you
also know someone you are someone who
knows trump very well what do you think
is going through his mind right now
because there's an incredibly
getting even larger amount of damning
testimony that's coming out and
noticeably he did not attack pat
cipolloni before sipoloni testified
before the 1-6 committee
yeah good morning katie i i think neil
carriel summed it up quite nicely i you
know uh to say that donald is terrified
is accurate and also an understatement
um i think this might be the first time
in his entire life
that even he can't deny the walls may
indeed be closing in uh the amount of
evidence that that we've seen coming out
at these committee hearings is
overwhelming
but
even more troubling for him is the
witnesses now coming forward so i mean
like yeah it's interesting
but it has a sort of like daytime tv
feel thing to it rather than real
journalism because mary trump has no
contact with trump and she hasn't for a
long time
and let's imagine she's right about
trump's fears and state of mind right
now which she may well be
it's possible to come to that same
conclusion from what's available
publicly in fact i have come to the same
conclusion so that that's one piece of
it and the continued mary trump
interviews on the other hand you know
when it comes to accountability
accountability has to be real it can't
just be discussed it can't just be well
accountability is all these people made
you look really guilty during their
testimony okay that's fine but it's got
to lead to something and maybe if trump
is held accountable at some point
we can sort of define a line that can't
be crossed and it would be quite a low
bar but if we can't even do that then
this is just going to happen again and
we've talked before about how right now
because there have been no real
consequences for donald trump to
everything that he did and i won't give
you the full list because i'm sure at
this point you're sick of hearing it
it's not evident that you can't cross
the lines we're not really a democracy
in the sense of checks and balances one
person one vote etc
if you can have checks and balances that
don't actually keep anyone in check and
balanced against their uh
fascistic tendencies
and we don't know what's taking so long
now to some degree it takes a while to
build cases and if there are indictments
from doj it may take some time
but for now it is not clear that we even
have an infrastructure willing and able
to assign consequences and repercussions
for what has taken place so interesting
to hear from mary trump i don't really
know that at this point she really knows
any more than any of us do because of
how long she hasn't been in touch with
donald trump all of us have had the
experience of dropping out of an
important zoom call because of a flaky
wi-fi connection i've had it when live
streaming if you can think of something
more humiliating let me know
uh something else i struggle with is
when i'm on the go
finding a good enough connection to
upload or download large video files
which i regularly need to do
what if you could fix all of this by
using more than one internet connection
at the same time like the coffee shop
wi-fi
and your mobile phones connection
combining them into one
super internet connection that's faster
and more reliable our sponsor speedify
is the only app that can combine
multiple internet sources into one
fantastic
super connection like this this will
improve your live streaming your video
calling your gaming the web browsing
everything you do online use speedify on
all devices pc mac iphone android linux
works with any type of internet
connection simple to use
runs in the background i use it
everywhere especially when traveling and
it works great try speedify risk free
for seven days
and get twenty percent off go to
speedify.com pacman and use the code
pacman click the link down in the
description